you just have to continue to keep
dreaming bigger and that's why it's so
important to always continue learning
all you can do is do your best even when
you make mistakes sometimes those can be
the most important experiences to learn
from
I've always been an entrepreneur at
heart I love the idea of starting a
business that's always been a dream of
mine
long before modeling need motivation
watch a top 10 with belief nation what's
up at 7 my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see exploded onto the world so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a woman who went
from being the daughter of a freelance
director and emergency physician to
becoming a model Victoria's Secret Angel
and entrepreneur she's Karlie Kloss and
here's my take on her top 10 rows of
success enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one my personal favorite do what
you love growing up in a house in the
Midwest you show love by feeding people
so for me I've always loved to cook and
bake for others and I started a charity
project called Carly's cookies to donate
school lunches to kids through selling
vegan cookies totally crazy idea but it
combined all my passions and it was a
way that I could actually make a
meaningful impact by doing what I love
and I think that that is when you're
most successful and fulfilled when you
pick both those boxes when you do what
you love and lead from that place first
and foremost and whatever you're trying
to accomplish I think that comes
naturally when it's from a place of just
passion because you have to work long
days and long nights and if you're not
enjoying what you're doing then it's
probably not a recipe for success
rule number two is take control hi guys
I'm Carly class and welcome to my
youtube channel
clearly run your brand over a billion
users for YouTube so you look at those
numbers and say this is smart business
it did I had an opportunity to do
something with a channel with Network
that was ultimately going to be in the
hands of producers and editors in a dark
room somewhere but I didn't have control
of it and and I had that realization and
I realized I want to control my story
rule number three dream bigger goals
continue to change and continue to get
bigger and I think as I as I sort of
reached certain milestones certain
accomplishments you know it only makes
me realize that I need to dream bigger
and I think that same thing for you guys
I think as you really build that
confidence through your career as you
really start start you know building
your career and building your
relationships and seeing your dreams
actually realized you just have to
continue
- keep dreaming bigger and that's why
it's so important to always continue
learning in my opinion because there's
always there's there you've never made
it I think we all can always continue to
do its do more to be better and bigger
Rula more form start your day right when
I want to just calm down I guess and
have a good day I try to wake up a
little early so you like listen to music
have my coffee and do all those things
yeah you clearly don't have time to do
any of that oh no and now more so I have
time to do okay and and I've made time
to do that you know I think that's the
thing something I've learned that you
can't just keep running around no
otherwise you're gonna burn yourself out
so I wake up early because I like to
take my time have breakfast I love to
workout first thing in the morning
because I feel like I have more energy
in the morning and just immediately get
it out of the way you know and you can
shower and you know do your makeup put
you know cream on get dressed and then
and then sort of start your day so yeah
but that's big guys she exercises in the
mornings we have no excuse I mean really
no excuses I just think it gives me more
energy I feel like well I feel lethargic
and tired if I don't but when you
actually like make time get your butt to
the gym you actually end up feeling so
much more energized rule number five
take your work seriously you said about
sort of a lot is riding on on you as a
model I know you know you have no
responsibility really than just to show
up but I think that that's one thing
that I I have grown an appreciation for
is all the work that goes into leading
up to that moment all the incredible
people that are involved - the editors
the interns the stylists the hair and
makeup the photographer's everybody's
sort of preparing in their own way and
so it's not like you can just sort of
show up because so much money so much
time so many people are involved before
that point so I think that rocks moment
and then
you have to make it home all time
together which is like kind of scary as
hell but also like really you know it
makes you um I don't know I think it's
it it sort of made me take this
seriously that it's not just sort of
like oh hey let's go like take pretty
pictures and put makeup on it's like
actually this is important well it's it
for business not a lifestyle business
rule number six just do your best
one of the first ballet recitals that I
danced in pointe shoes and I was so
nervous because it was the first time
that I was gonna get on stage everyone
that I loved and care about was going to
be in that audience and I didn't want to
let him down I didn't want to let myself
down how I sort of learned to cope with
that it's just really to take that
anxiety that that sort of adrenaline and
actually pour it into something
productive meaning like what can you do
to best prepare for that moment so when
it came to the point where it was
Showtime it was time to get out on that
stage I knew that I did everything I
possibly could to get out there and feel
amazing and just perform and I think
something clicked in me however it
doesn't always go right there was a time
I remember I walked in a Fendi runway
show and I you know made a little slip
and kind of slipped off the runway and
but all you can do is do your best even
when you make mistakes sometimes those
can be the most important experiences to
learn from rule number seven keep
learning they happened to be a closeted
super nerd
[Music]
so I personally have begun learning how
to program on my own because programming
is the language of the future and of now
I wish I would have started learning at
13 but it doesn't matter how old you are
you can always start learning jump into
it learn it just try and take one class
give it one hour it's amazing what you
can learn in one hour it's important to
break that stigma of thinking that it's
not cool to be smart if you can
understand much less speak code you can
build anything rule number eight is
don't lose yourself it's a really
difficult thing to do though just sort
of separate you as a physical being
versus you as who you truly are I think
that sort of especially being that we
start our careers at such a young age it
is challenging at times to sort of
separate the two like you know you go to
work and you play dress-up and you
become a million different characters
but how do you not lose you and and I
think that that's something that is is
definitely you know you know and we're
still finding ourselves I mean I find at
least I am I and I'm 21 years old and so
I think that that's I don't know
something that you know being not
getting lost in in rule number nine have
an entrepreneurial spirit
growing up I loved science but I never
had computer science coding engineering
classes and it wasn't until I went years
later to go take a bootcamp and learn
basics and how to code and I really
realized how valuable that skill set is
even just that understanding of how
technology works is super valuable
I've always been an entrepreneur at
heart I love the idea of starting a
business that's always been a dream of
mine
long before modeling the beauty of the
world we live in today
the power of code is that you can
actually take an idea doesn't matter who
you are or what kind of formal education
you have and build it out yourself or
understand what is possible to build
then that's why it doesn't matter that
I'm a model there's opportunity for
anyone to be an entrepreneur a rule
number ten the last one before the bonus
clip have fun I'm Caroline portrait of
each other that yeah favor are licking
your hand
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Karlie's
I've got a special Carly bonus clip on
being good to yourself but before that
my question of the day
I love how Carly has a whole bunch of
hyphens to her she's a model she's an
entrepreneur
she likes to code she likes science she
likes nerding out you know what are the
different things that make up your
hyphens how do you describe yourself I
want you to pick five different hyphens
that make you you your this this this
this and this
put hyphens in between leaving the
comments below I want to see what you
got thank you guys so much for watching
I believe in you
I hope continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clip
I can do for myself is is be good to me
be good to my body and you know getting
a workout in is for me the best way to
beat jetlag the best way to just kind of
stay energized and so we're gonna kick
off this morning with a good workout I
definitely find that in my life you know
health and wellness and fitness and
strength in the body and in the mind is
is so important it helps me be the best
version of myself and I really am never
done on that journey women are really I
grew up in a house of women I have three
sisters or my mom and you know I think
we are resilient and powerful and
sometimes too hard on ourselves so I
think you have to also I think self-care
self-love is is
is always a good thing so as long as
you're setting goals to be the best
version of yourself raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
means that people need passion and not
one drop of myself work depends on your
it's supposed to mean I don't ever give
up I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
rows of success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link the
description for details